[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers guten abend hinein und
schon mal vorweg danke dass sie bei uns
sind kristin hält sich über alles
wichtige vom sport auf dem laufenden
olympia hat herr guten abend und das
sind die wichtigsten themen am anfang
dieser neuen woche der impf angebote für
zwölf- bis 17-jährige das haben die
gesundheitsminister von bund und ländern
beschlossen und stellen sich damit gegen
die ständige impfkommission wurden die
menschen im aartal zu spät gewarnt und
evakuiert die staatsanwaltschaft prüft
jetzt ermittlungen zur flutkatastrophe
und doppeltes gold ringerin aline rotter
focken und vielseitigkeitsreiterin julia
krajewski feiern olympiasiege wir
beginnen mit der diskussion um corona
impfungen für kinder und jugendliche
die gesundheitsminister von bund und
ländern haben dafür heute den weg frei
gemacht alle 12 bis 17 jährigen sollen
ein angebot bekommen
damit erhöht die politik den druck auf
die experten der ständigen
impfkommission die eher skeptisch sind
unter anderem weil es noch zu wenige
daten zu möglichen folgeschäden gebe an
seinem stern fasst die aktuelle fakten
lage zusammen
kinder jugendliche und die kogit
impfspritzen klar ist für 12 bis 17
jährige in deutschland empfiehlt die
stiko die ständige impfkommission diese
spritze nur in bestimmten fällen etwa
bei vorerkrankungen wie immunschwäche
oder fettleibigkeit eine allgemeine
corona impfempfehlung gibt es hier nicht
ein grund so die wissenschaftler
die fehlenden daten es gebe noch zu
wenig studien zu wenig wissen etwa über
nebenwirkungen und risiken anders sehen
das die zuständigen experten in den usa
oder bei der eu die europäische
arzneimittelagentur ema hat eine
allgemeine impfempfehlung ausgesprochen
ab 12 jahren für die wirkstoffe von
biontech und moderner auch bei den
jüngeren seien diese impfstoffe wirksam
und sicher
das hätten die bisherigen studien klar
gezeigt dass ist die lage viele familien
stehen jetzt vor der frage kinder impfen
ja oder nein
in deutschland gibt es etwa 4,5
millionen 12
zehnjährige 900.000 haben sich bislang
impfen lassen gegen korona das risiko
von kindern schwer zu erkranken sei sehr
gering sagen die stiko fachleute
wichtiger sei bei den erwachsenen eine
höhere impfquote zu erreichen
die politik dagegen hat jetzt gerade
schülerinnen und schüler im blick weil
in den ersten bundesländern die
sommerferien zu ende gehen christiane
hübscher mit mehr
es ist eine der meistdiskutierten fragen
im moment soll ich mein kind impfen
lassen ja sagt die politik in einer
video konferenz der gesundheitsminister
der länder mit jens spahn ist soeben
eine extra impfkampagne für zwölf- bis
17-jährige beschlossen worden was das
thema der kinder und jugend impfungen
angeht haben wir einen einstimmigen
beschluss gefasst dass wir dieses
angebot jetzt in allen ländern
unterbreiten wollen wir wollen dann
zusätzlich im september dann auch in die
schulen gehen und dort noch einmal diese
impf angebote machen und da wirklich
alles auch auszuloten wer des will kann
das dann noch annehmen damit über geht
die politik die ständige impfkommission
kurz stiko die empfiehlt die kurve
kämpfen bisher nur für vor erkrankte
kinder stieg josef merkens reagiert
gereizt ich halte den druck den die
politik ausübt eigentlich für wenig ist
die debatte über kinder impfungen seien
nur eine stellvertreter diskussion zu
den weiteren verlauf der pandemie in
deutschland wäre es absolut erforderlich
dass sich die 18 bis 59 jährigen
vollständig mit dem reichlich
verfügbaren impfstoff impfen lassen
die kinder spielen für die epidemiologie
in deutschland und für den schotter
aufstände wie eine ausgesprochen
untergeordnete rolle
doch die impfbereitschaft der
erwachsenen stagniert dazu kommt der
schulstart in mehreren bundesländern
deshalb setzt die politik nun offensiv
auf die jüngeren
niemand übt druck auf die impfungen von
kindern und jugendlichen ist
allein entscheidungen der eltern
gemeinsam mit ihren kindern und das wird
auch so bleiben
die politik schafft fakten die stiko
zögert verunsichert zurück bleiben viele
eltern und kinder noch mal reden mit
patricia wiedemeier in berlin gute namen
patricia da prallen jetzt zwei
sichtweisen aufeinander die einen machen
eine individuelle risiko abwägung für
kinder und für die politik ist impfen
jetzt auch teil der schulen strategie
wie lässt sich das dann den eltern
vermitteln die da irgendwie mittendrin
sitzen ja das dürfte schwierig werden
bisher hat sich die regierung ja an die
empfehlungen der wissenschaft der
ständigen impfkommission gehalten
das soll jetzt nicht mehr geltend schwer
zu erklären eine allgemeine impfpflicht
für erwachsene lehnt die regierung ab
aber auf kinder und eltern wird nun der
druck erhöht
eltern die lange zeit homeschooling
praktiziert haben werden wohl alles tun
um erneute schulschließungen zu
verhindern und ihre kinder auch entgegen
dem rat mancher ärzte dann impfen lassen
sehr schwer zu erklären wird dieses
sicherlich auch wenn auf der anderen
seite die impfbereitschaft bei den 18
bis 59 jährigen nachlässt und sich der
bayerische wirtschaftsminister zum
beispiel weigert sich selber impfen zu
lassen
es bleibt der eindruck dass mit dem
heutigen beschluss versucht wird einer
herdenimmunität näher zu kommen
die eltern aber werden alleine gelassen
stehen vor der schwierigen entscheidung
glauben sie den gesundheitsministern und
ministerinnen oder der stiko potenzial
wieder mal berlin herzlichen dank für
diese einschätzung heute abend
jugendliche impfen was spricht dafür was
spricht dagegen sie können
mitdiskutieren
in einem zdf heute live unter anderem
mit einem mitglied der ständigen
impfkommission um 19 uhr 30 das ganze in
der heute app auf youtube und facebook
drehen wir die zeit mal sechs wochen
zurück im ganzen land sanken die korona
zahlen in schleswig holstein und
mecklenburg vorpommern starteten die
sommerferien
die kinder und jugendlichen hatten ein
stressiges corona schuljahr hinter sich
und jetzt geht es wieder los
aber die unsicherheit ist zu beginn des
neuen schuljahrs so groß wie zum ende
des letzten beatrice steinicke und bernd
mosebach berichten
die 9c ist zurück aus den sommerferien
das gerhart hauptmann gymnasium in
wismar
es herrscht masken pflicht auf dem
schulhof auf den fluren und in allen
räumen und eine testpflicht fast alle
lehrkräfte hier sind mittlerweile
komplett geimpft für die schüler gibt es
ein angebot im fokus der kampagne der
bildungsministerin stehen zunächst
jugendliche ab 16
in der ersten woche wird der bedarf
abgefragt wir werden dann ab der zweiten
woche mobile teams in die
weiterführenden schulen schicken damit
die größeren die sich ja schon in
verlassen können dann auch impfen lassen
und nach eingehender beratung können ja
auch ab 12 jährige kinder schon geimpft
werden das ist aber eine entscheidung
die dann mit dem arzt gemeinsam
getroffen werden muss einige schüler der
9c sind der politik bereits einen
schritt voraus
ich habe mich schon aber ich kann gut
verstehen wenn leute noch auf die
empfehlung der stiko warten weil das
risiko dass die jüngere schwerer
erkranken deutlich geringer und ja ich
finde dass leute jeder individuell
entscheiden
ausbaufähig ist weiterhin die
ausstattung der schulen etwa mit luft
reinigungstechnik wir hätten ein
flächendeckendes investitionsprogramm
für luft reinigungsanlagen benötigt um
eben gerade die gruppen zu schützen die
sich nicht schützen können zum beispiel
die kinder unter 12 jahre
dass die ja noch kein angebot bekommen
können flächendeckende schulschließungen
etwa für komplette landkreise will die
landesregierung im neuen schuljahr
möglichst vermeiden die gesundheitsämter
vor ort sollen individuell entscheiden
auf manche menschen kommt im herbst wohl
eine dritte impfung zu um den schutz vor
dem virus aufzufrischen
auch das haben die gesundheitsminister
beschlossen betroffen sind zunächst die
die als erste geimpft wurden hoch
betagte pflegebedürftige und menschen
mit einer immunschwäche
jetzt sind er seine unser nächstes
großes thema seit die verheerenden
überschwemmungen das aartal heimsuchten
mehren sich kritische fragen war der tod
von mehr als 130 menschen wirklich nicht
zu vermeiden
hätte man nicht früher warnen und
evakuieren können oder müssen
jetzt werden die vorwürfe konkreter der
landkreis ahrweiler soll auf dringende
warnungen der landesbehörden erst mit
verzögerung reagiert haben die
staatsanwaltschaft prüft bobby cherry an
berichtet das aufräumen im kreis
ahrweiler läuft weiter und eine frage
geht weiter um haben die behörden vor
der flutkatastrophe fehler begangen
nach der verheerenden unwetter
katastrophe im aartal prüft die
staatsanwaltschaft koblenz die
einleitung eines ermittlungsverfahrens
wegen des anfangsverdachts der
fahrlässigen tötung und der fahrlässigen
körperverletzung in folge möglicherweise
unterlassener oder verspäteter warnungen
oder evakuierungen der bevölkerung gegen
wen sich der verdacht konkret richtet
blieb heute offen
experten kritisieren vor allem den
landrat des kreises ahrweiler
dieser habe am 14 juli viel zu spät den
katastrophenfall ausgerufen
obwohl das landesumweltamt bereits um
acht uhr abends besorgniserregend hohe
pegelstände meldete man saß wohl weiter
zusammen hat aber anders als andere
landkreise erst viel später nämlich um
23 uhr neuen katastrophenalarm ausgelöst
und das muss der landrat lässt sich
erklären für ein interview stand der
landrat dem zdf heute nicht zur
verfügung viele menschen im kreis
ahrweiler sagen die deutlichen warnungen
kamen hier zu spät
es gab zwar allgemeine hinweise auf
hochwasser aber im entscheidenden moment
am abend des 14
juli als das wasser rasant stieg gab es
weder im megaphon ansagen noch sirenen
die wahren apps fielen zum teil aus und
so wurden viele menschen ahnungslos im
schlaf vom wasser überrascht fast drei
wochen liegt die hochwasserkatastrophe
zurück seitdem wird aufgeräumt
jetzt beginnt die rechtliche
aufarbeitung wenn sie den menschen im
katastrophengebiet helfen wollen das
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe hat ein
spendenkonto eingerichtet
die iban lautet de 65 104 106 100 104
106 100 stichwort zdf hochwasser weitere
informationen auch im internet und im
zdf text seit tagen schon wütenden
zahlreichen urlaubsregionen am
mittelmeer verheerende waldbrände
besonders kritisch ist die lage in der
türkei hier sind vor allem die provinzen
antalya und muller im südwesten
betroffen viele feuer die bereits
gelöscht waren werden durch starke winde
wieder angefacht touristen und
einheimische müssen teils mit booten in
sicherheit gebracht werden
bisher kamen acht menschen ums leben
glück walbrodt berichtet das feuer
frisst sich rasend schnell den hügel
hinunter auf hotels und häfen zu wie
hier in marmaris sind zahlreiche
urlaubsorte zwischen antalya und bodrum
bedroht weil die ausfallstraßen schon in
flammen standen mussten gestern diese
urlaubsgäste in höchster not in booten
übers meer gerettet werden 132 brände an
der küste aber auch im landesinneren so
die amtlichen zahlen 4000 feuerwehrleute
sind im einsatz russland die europäische
union und die ukraine haben dass
flugzeuge geschickt trotzdem sind bürger
in einzelnen orten bei temperaturen von
mehr als 40 grad noch allein im kampf
gegen die flammen in gottes namen
schickt endlich hilfe wir brauchen
hubschrauber wie sollen wir das selbst
aus der luft bekämpfen mit den
wassereimer und kommen wir nicht weit wo
bleibt die regierung die verstecken sich
inzwischen hat ankara 5 millionen euro
nothilfe bereit gestellt neben
zahlreichen häusern wurden auch über
90.000 hektar wald und oliven plantagen
zerstört sieben mal so viel wie in
anderen jahren
ein großteil der brände sei unter
kontrolle heißt es brandstiftung wird
als mögliche ursache nicht
ausgeschlossen wir werden zu den
ermittlungen jetzt nichts sagen das
würde mehr schaden als nutzen
experten glauben dass vor allem der
klimawandel unzureichender
landschaftsschutz und vielerorts auch
unachtsamkeit ursachen der katastrophe
sind ähnlich dramatisch wie in der
türkei ist die situation auch in anderen
ländern am mittelmeer
die menschen kämpfen auch in
griechenland gegen viele waldbrände wie
hier auf der insel rhodos dazu kommt
aktuell die schlimmste hitzewelle seit
jahrzehnten mit temperaturen bis 45 grad
in italien sind vor allem der süden und
die adria-küste betroffen starke winde
fachen die brände immer wieder an
italien hat andere länder um
unterstützung gebeten und löschflugzeuge
angefordert und jetzt zu einem schiff
der bundeswehr und seiner mission die
offiziell als präsenz und
ausbildungsfahrt gilt und doch so viel
mehr ist
heute startet die fregatte bayern in
wilhelmshaven in see ein halbes jahr
lang soll sie im indopazifik kreuzen
also in der gegend die in etwa vom horn
von afrika südlich bis australien und
östlich bis hinter japan reicht aus dem
grund für die fahrt macht die bundeswehr
keinen hehl gemeinsam mit partner
ländern wie den usa will man den
machtansprüchen chinas in der gegend
etwas entgegensetzen andreas ruppert
alles bereit für die große fahrt das
ziel der indopazifik die mission präsenz
zeigen in einer region die
geopolitischen wirtschaftlich zu den
wohl wichtigsten im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert gehört deshalb hat die
bundesregierung entschieden deutschland
soll dabei nicht außen vor bleiben
der in der pazifik ist ein raum der für
uns von interesse ist auch dort geht es
um regelbasierte ordnung auf der von der
wir profitieren und wir sind gemeinsam
mit den partnern vor ort um etwa die
freiheit der schifffahrt auch zu
garantieren
es sind vor allem die usa und frankreich
die deutschen an ihrer seite sehen
wollen um gewalt dem machtstreben der
chinesen im indopazifik entgegenzutreten
den peking erhebt territoriale ansprüche
in der region rüstet dort erheblich
aufbaut auf atollen zum beispiel
modernste militärbasen
der innovative ist die wirtschaftliche
aufstrebende region die globalen
warenströme verlaufen durch die region
so dass natürlich jede störung durch
regionale krisen sich auch bei uns
bemerkbar machen würde
vor ort sollen die gut 230 soldatinnen
und soldaten an bord der bayern an
übungen und manövern mit verbündeten
teilnehmen völlig überflüssig sei diese
mission sagt die linke und das auch noch
ohne zustimmung des bundestages es ist
ein fataler fehler es ist ein
hintergehen des bundestages es ist eine
konfrontation und trägt nicht zur
sicherheit bei sondern ganz im gegenteil
bis februar ist die bayern unterwegs
schon jetzt so ist zu hören soll das
nicht die letzte deutsche mission im
indopazifik bleiben
so und jetzt zu olympia und zum
dramatischen kampf einer sportlerin aus
belarus nicht um medaillen sondern um
ihre freiheit christina tiemann offs
kaya hatte es gewagt belarussische
funktionäre öffentlich zu kritisieren
daraufhin sollte sie nach hause zurück
schaffte es aber auf dem flughafen in
tokio sich abzusetzen annegret oster
berichtet die polnische botschaft in
tokio ankunft von christina tiemann of
scale ist dass das vorläufige ende einer
gewaltsam versuchten entführung ihrer
eigenen sportlerin durch die bälle
russischen machthaber diesen hilferuf
veröffentlichte die sprinterin gestern
abend ich bitte das internationale
olympische komitee um hilfe ich bin
unter druck gesetzt worden und sie
versuchen mich gegen meinen willen aus
japan auszufliegen
zimanowski hatte den flug verweigert bei
der japanischen polizei hilfe gesucht
und anschließend die nacht in einem
hotel am flughafen verbracht die neue
heimat der 24-jährigen wird wohl polen
werden fahrschülern oscar hat ein
humanitäres visum beantragt dieses visum
wird ihr natürlich erteilt wir haben
hier die möglichkeit angeboten ihrer
sportlichen aktivitäten in polen
fortzusetzen
die menschenrechtsorganisation human
rights watch und der verein der athleten
deutschland haben das ioc dazu
aufgerufen entschlossen gegen das fehler
russische olympische komitee vorzugehen
so und rein sportlich heute bei olympia
christin ein sehr gut hat vor allem mega
frauenpower julia gajewski hat als erste
frau olympisches gold in der
vielseitigkeit gewonnen die 32-jährige
sichert sich als letzte reiterin im
springparcours äußerst nervenstark
diesen triumph der vierte für
deutschland bei olympia nacheinander
da regt sie die faust zum himmel die
freude einfach grenzenlos nach dem ritt
ihres lebens vielseitigkeitsreiterin
julia krajewski
die 32-jährige aus warendorf bleibt dem
abschließenden springen auf ihrer stute
am mount genannt mandy ohne abwurf
gewinnt gold mir durch den kopf wie
viele menschen hinter mir stehen und
immer an mich geglaubt haben und
in den ganzen höhen und tiefen für mich
da war der erfolg von julia krajewski
ist historisch als erste frau gewinnt
sie olympisches gold in der
einzelwertung
silber holt der brite tom mclean und
bronze der australier andrew hoy
[Musik]
historischer erfolg auch im ringen aline
rotter focken bejubelt als erste
deutsche ringerin den olympiasieg im
letzten kampf ihrer karriere entscheidet
die 30 jährige das finale in der klasse
bis 76 kilogramm für sich weit weg und
irgendwie doch ganz nah dabei familie
und freunde von aline rotter focken im
moment ihres größten sportlichen
triumphes souverän und überraschend
zugleich setzt sich die 30 jährige im
finale gegen die fünfmalige
weltmeisterin in gray aus den usa durch
[Applaus]
kein schlechtes drehbuch dass sie das
schrieb denn mit olympia beendet aline
focken nun ihre aktive laufbahn einer
sportlichen sensation gleich das
olympische silber von kristin pudenz im
diskuswerfen der frauen im regenchaos
von tokio und nach final unterbrechung
wirft sie als außenseiterin mit 66
metern 86 persönliche bestweite und wird
hinter der olympiasiegerin valerie
ahlmann usa überglücklich zweite und
noch mehr silber für deutsche frauen am
ersten tag der bahnrad wettbewerbe im
olympischen velodrom für das duo
immerhin zu leo so friedrich ganz knapp
hinter den chinesen in einem packenden
team sprint finale ihre erste olympische
medaille und ein bisschen haderten emma
hinzu und lea-sophie friedrich zunächst
sogar mit silber das gold das war zum
greifen nahe und zwar so so knapp
letztendlich sind wir natürlich stolz
dass wir eine medaille tragen können
mehr als drei zehntelsekunden liegen sie
zurück nach der ersten runde im finale
gegen die chinesinnen emma hinzu aber
zieht sich hundertstel um 100
am ende fehlt weniger als eine
zehntelsekunde zum gold und beide können
sich über silber freuen
mehr von olympia im heute journal
jede menge medaillen vielen dank
christian guckt mir aufs wetter das
bringt morgen von westen weitere schwere
gewitter da sollten wir genau zuhören
gleich bei ist intelli dann empfehle ich
ihnen natürlich das heute-journal 21.45
mit der kollegin marietta slomka für
heute von uns allen hier im team 19
danke fürs zuschauen und ihnen einen
angenehmen abend
[Musik]
sogenannte und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter solange die nativ komplex vom
atlantik über nord afrika bis in den
osten europas über uns liegt werden
weitere unwetter mit gewittern über uns
hinweg ziehen oder das nächste steht
schon an und zwar richtung britische
inseln das überquert und dann morgen
einmal nach osten der kommenden nacht
gekommen die wolken allmählich im westen
auf und da sind dann schauer dabei vor
allem den frühstunden sonst ist es erst
mal trocken und das bei temperaturen bis
9 grad im nordwesten und an den alpen
und 13 grad an der ostsee morgen in der
nordhälfte überwiegend trockenes wetter
mit sonnigen abschnitten aber zum
nachmittag vor allem von westen nach
osten zieht das gewittertief mit
heftigen gewittern und vor allem im
süden teils mit unwetter starkregen
hagel und sturmböen
gerade mal im osten bleibt es zunächst
noch trocken und dann später auch dort
die gewitter das bei temperaturen bis 23
grad im osten deutschlands und 17 grad
nach westen hin die kommenden tage am
mittwoch bis 23 grad warm weitere
schauer folgende südhälfte donnerstag
ist es dann ebenfalls unbeständig und
wieder mit gewittern und damit ein
schöner abend